it's Thursday so we all know what that
means today is Theory Thursday what's up
everybody my name is Warren and thanks
for joining me here at my channel today
we have some great theories lined up for
those of you who are new theory
Thursdays is a segment I do every
Thursday where I pick theories you all
submit to me to enter a monthly
competition each week you all vote for
the theory that you like the most and at
the end of the month you all vote for
your overall favorite theory the overall
theory that wins will win the monthly
prize right now the monthly price is an
IMAX gift card so you and a friend can
go see whatever movie you'd like in IMAX
so if you have any theories of your own
don't forget to submit them in the email
address in my description for your
chance to end up on Theory Thursday you
all voted and last week's winner was
theory number three Samuel from Puerto
Rico with a theory on how Avengers
endgame will go down congratulations to
Samuel and you are now entered into the
pool of champions and are eligible to
win the monthly prize at the end of the
month this week's theories are really
really something we have some great
theories to go over this week so let's
get started theory number one this week
comes from Johan Johan is 18 years old
from Sweden and has a theory about the
plot for avengers endgame Johan believes
that Thanos who is currently watching
the sunset on Titan 2 will reflect on
his actions and regret losing everything
as he himself said in Avengers infinity
war meaning the loss of Gamora
he will then use the remaining power of
the Infinity Gauntlet to bring her back
from soul world however doing that will
surely mean the loss of the soul stone
because of the sacrifice needed to
collect a stone in the first place this
combined with a now permanently damaged
and useless gauntlet will give the
Avengers a chance to collect the stones
by fighting and defeating Thanos and in
the end through a self-sacrifice and
using all of the Infinity stones they
will bring everybody back the stones
will then be secured only obtainable
through a new kind of sacrifice Johan
believes that if this does in fact
happen it will only be in the last act
of the movie act 1 and act 2 will then
be used to try time-travel but
ultimately fail because of time travel
paradoxes the avengers will instead
after
trying to use time travel focus on where
Thanos is and spy on him to find his
weaknesses so they can defeat him in the
future and this is Johanna theory
there's a lot that I like to this theory
I think it ties in really well with
infinity war and endgame especially the
part about Thanos losing everything and
missing Gamora and eventually bringing
her back it was pretty obvious that the
only thing or person who Thanos really
loved was Gamora and now he sacrificed
her so maybe it's not all worth it if he
had to sacrifice the one thing he loved
his daughter I also think that the time
travel paradoxes makes sense as well
there's so many things that can go wrong
by changing the events in the past and I
do think that the Avengers will try to
go in the past change things go back to
the future and realize that it's not
what they thought it was and they
actually got it wrong and maybe changing
the events from the past is not the
solution to defeating Thanos so that's
it for theory number one now on to
theory number two theory number two
comes from Myka Quinn and Myka has a
Captain Marvel slash in game theory Myka
believes that because of the kree-skrull
war both factions are looking for
powerful weapons such as infinity stones
on earth so that leads the scrolls to
earth in search of these powerful
weapons and the Infinity stones the
scrolls get intelligence on the space
stone but they're not exactly sure where
it is so they decide to assimilate into
Earth's society based off their
intelligence they find out that Howard
Stark may have the space stone or at
least knows where it is and they find
out that the ancient one has the time
stone
the Kree then find out about these
Infinity stones and sin yan raw to go
and get them before the scroll do yan
rod goes to get the tesseract from Stark
Stark has the tesseract hooked up to a
mysterious device maybe the psyche
magnetron from the comics but the
scrolls are already undercover in Stark
Industries so they chase young Rob
Captain Marvel is also there working for
project Pegasus so she chases them to
try to get the tesseract back she ends
up getting hit by waves from the
tesseract and the mysterious device and
that unlocks her powers young Raj sees
that she survives and decides to take
her instead of the tesseract and the
Kree heal her and decide to brainwash
her and use her for a weapon the Kree
decided to send Star Force back to earth
were they once again try to fight the
scrolls but Carol Danvers ends up
getting knocked down to earth where she
suffers from amnesia
and falls into Blockbuster Mika believes
that Captain Marvel will wander some of
the movie with a who am i scenario but
when Captain Marvel sees a scroll her
programming kicks in and she ends up
chasing a scroll on the bus which is
where she will meet fury Mika lists a
few more points to her theory stating
that she believes a scroll will have a
base underwater Captain Marvel will
befriend a scroll and they reverse some
of the effects from her brainwashing but
she figures out both factions are lying
and decides not to trust anybody the
power from the space stone / tesseract
gives Captain Marvel the power to go
through pocket dimensions / the quantum
realm sort of like time travel or her
cat goose has that power she meets fury
and they test on her and figure out that
she has an implant in her skull and she
suffers from amnesia and schizophrenia
traits which is an easter egg from dr.
strange sometime in the movie Nick Fury
gets switched with a scroll and tries to
steal the Fleur conduce Captain Marvel
figures out what's going on and ends up
blasting the ronk fury and he loses an
eye Captain Marvel's mom was half Korean
sent to earth to locate the Infinity
stones this is based off with a comic by
Margaret Stohl captain Marvel's movie
will end with more questions than
answers and she still will not
understand who she is or what she is or
who her parents are and this will lead
up to the second movie the alpha fight
team and shield / earth will be
developed by Tony Stark and sherry after
avengers endgame and that's it for
Mika's theory this was certainly well
thought out with a lot of scenarios that
could definitely happen in Captain
Marvel it makes a lot of sense that the
Kree and the scroll would go to earth
because of the current Infinity stones
there and it also makes a lot of sense
that the tesseract which is the space
stone gives Captain Marvel her powers
which is also how she can travel through
time which samuel l.jackson told us that
she could we obviously know that the
Kree take her back and turn her into a
weapon and we do know that some of the
scroll have infiltrated Stark Industries
or a government agency so again there
are a lot of possibilities in this
theory that could definitely happen in
Captain Marvel that wraps up theory
number 2 now on to theory number 3
theory number 3 comes from Gotham Ramesh
from Melbourne Australia with a theory
on how the beginning of Avengers in game
will happen Gotham says it begins with
Thanos on his farm in Titan two
peacefully and with pride because he
achieved his goal of balancing the
universe
little did he think
what the remaining superheroes would do
the remaining Avengers leave will
conduct to the Avengers facility to find
out how big of an impact the decimation
cost when they get there Pepper Potts is
already there waiting to show them a
message from Tony this is the same one
he recorded in the Avengers in-game
trailer rocket figures out that Tony is
on the Benatar and finds a way to track
it down meanwhile Captain Marvel returns
to earth and tries to find fury and goes
to the road where fury activated the
pager from the in credits scene of
infinity war then she goes to the hidden
shield facility and finds Kline who was
mentioned in the end credits scenes of
infinity war as well he takes Captain
Marvel to the Avengers facility there
everybody's busy trying to find a way to
get Tony back and trying to find out who
else has gone missing banner when he is
trying to check the missing people's
lists tries to connect with the Hulk and
resolve their issues Thor tries to find
dr. Selvig when he does find him he is
mortified of what happened and Thor
takes him to the facility and they start
discussing what happened
Natasha explains to Captain Marvel about
what Thanos did meanwhile rocket tells
Rhodey that he found a way to track down
the Benatar pepper insists that she
wants to go with rocket and at that time
road he gives her a bracelet that Tony
wanted to give her which is the same
bracelet from the first Avengers movie
which Tony uses to put on his suit but
this time it's the rescue suit she puts
on the suit and then her Rhodey and
Rocket go into space to get Tony and
nebula and Captain Marvel joins as well
in the meantime cap is trying to find
clues from shield files and archive
videos to find more agents to get ready
for a war and then he comes across a
video of ant-man and shows it to Thor
banner and Selvig to get answers when
Tony gets back he looks quite old due to
starvation and he finds out that time
travel is possible thanks to ant man's
video he then tells banner about barf
Tech and they try to find a way to reach
ant-man Tony then asked banner to
contact Wong and asked Wong to find a
way to communicate with dr. strange to
find out the outcome of what they're
about to do Wong ultimately says no
because having that knowledge of the
future is too dangerous and that does it
for Gotham's theory there is definitely
a lot from this theory that could happen
in Avengers in game a couple things that
Gotham mentioned that not a lot of
people really think about our Salvage
and climb we actually know that selvig's
survived the snap we know this from the
book Thanos Titan consumed
which ties directly into the MCU so
he'll probably have a role in Avengers
in-game Klein is also speculated to have
a pretty decent role he's mentioned in
the post credit scene for Avengers
infinity war and mentioned in the
Captain Marvel prelude comic and I
definitely think that he's going to be
the one to introduce Captain Marvel to
the rest of the Avengers and I do think
that in some way Wong will figure out
how to communicate with Doctor Strange
so that does it for theory number three
on to theory number four number four
comes from Thomas Roberts a 13 year old
from the UK his theory starts off with
Tony and nebula in space Tony is on the
brink of dying but he actually doesn't
think he will die instead he thinks that
a ship with the remaining as guardians
including Valkyrie Korg and meek will be
beaming a distress signal at the same
time Tony and nebula will also be
beaming a distress signal and the two of
them will find each other he says that
in the IMAX Avengers in-game trailer you
can see in one scene there's a bright
mysterious light coming from the right
side which he thinks could be the
Asgardian ship he thinks once they meet
up with their combined efforts they can
make their way back to earth Tony lives
and Thor gets to reunite with some of
his Asgardian family Thomas's theory is
short and simple but he could be on to
something here we just got some Avengers
in game toys and one of those was a toy
for Valkyrie so it does seem like
Valkyrie will be making an appearance in
Avengers in game and perhaps she's the
one who saves Tony in space so that does
it for theory number four on to the
final theory theory number five number
five comes from susan dolan and susan
has a theory on what villain is going to
pop up in the post-credits scene of
Avengers in game Susan says that all of
the villains that have been mentioned
for the post-credits scene of Avengers
in game are owned by Fox not by Marvel
and Disney Disney did buy Fox but the
deal is not completely done yet there's
still a lot that has to happen so Susan
says that the villain that will appear
in the post-credits scene of Avengers in
game will have to be currently owned by
Marvel and Disney as she has six names
of villains who could appear in the
post-credits scene for Avengers in Game
one
mangog to Kang the Conqueror 3 the High
Evolutionary for Archon the Magnificent
5 the sons of the serpent 6 nan more and
she says that she expects Namor the
Submariner
be in the post credit scene of Avengers
endgame Susan makes some really good
points
the Fox deal is not done yet they can't
use characters that Fox owns in the MCU
yet and Kevin Feige president of Marvel
Studios has even said that they do have
plans for all the characters entering
the MCU but nothing has even started
development yet so we are a few years
out until will see some Fox characters
into the MCU and Marvel Studios has
teased Namor a little bit so it's very
possible and that could also be a movie
that could rival Aquaman so Susan has
some pretty good points for her theory
so that does it for our five theories
for this week's Theory Thursday let's do
a recap theory number one is that Fanus
will miss Kimora and bring her back
therefore losing the soul stone from
here the Avengers will fight Thanos and
have to sacrifice somebody to get the
soul stone theory number two is how
Captain Marvel will play out the Kree
and the scroll will go to earth in
search of the Infinity stones and the
tesseract / the space stone is how
Captain Marvel gets her powers and is
able to travel through time theory
number three is how the beginning of
Avengers endgame will go down the
remaining Avengers regroup at the
Avengers facility with Captain Marvel
Thor goes and gets dr. Selvig and then
pepper rody rocket and Captain Marvel go
save Tony in space theory number 4 is
that Valkyrie Korg meek and the rest of
the Asgardians that survived will find
Tony and nebula they will save Tony and
from there they will all go back to
earth and regroup with pepper and Thor
and theory number five is that in the
post-credits scene for Avengers in game
we will be introduced to a new villain
and that new villain will have to
currently be owned by Disney and Marvel
and this theory states that that villain
will be Namor the Submariner so there
you have it the five theories for this
week's Theory Thursday be sure to vote
on which one was your favorite and if
you have any theories of your own and
want to enter them for a chance to end
up on Theory Thursdays you can send them
to cosmic Theory Thursdays at gmail.com
the email and the instructions are in
the description down below again I want
to thank you all for supporting my new
segment and if you're new be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on all Theory Thursdays
Marvel Avengers in game and all things
superhero as always thank you all so
much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]